[Music]
what's up everybody carlos here
for the last several weeks juan division
has been our collective obsession it's
almost like we
are the residents of west view getting
caught up in some tv
magic now of course you have your
thoughts and fan theories
and that's what i wanted to talk about
today so if you haven't seen episode
five yet
spoilers but if you have we're just
gonna have a lot of fun talking about
the fan theories coming
from you guys this is et canada's
nervous
[Applause]
long-lost bro get to squeeze his
stinking sister to death or what okay
let's begin by discussing the
end the big reveal at the end of the
episode that is uncle pietro walking
through wanda and vision's door
is a huge moment that opens up a ton of
story possibilities and theories one of
which
was brought up by john webb in our
comments wanda didn't bring pietro
back the boys did do you have a brother
mom
i do he's
far away from here and that makes me
sad sometimes now wanda has no magical
control over her kids which
if you've ever looked after kids you'll
know this is the most realistic part of
the series
but they do seem to have powers of their
own as evidenced by their ability to
spontaneously age themselves up five
years at a time
and we know that in the comics the boys
are created using a combination of
wanda's mutant powers
magic and pieces of mephisto's
soul like the soul of the devil
so the mcu doesn't typically follow the
comics to the letter
but if they use a version of this origin
story for the twins then their mere
presence
means big universe shaping things are
about to happen
wanda says she didn't cause that
doorbell to ring
so if the boys do have powers maybe they
were just sick and tired of mom dragging
her feet about the whole
fixing dead thing and decided they want
to start taking control of this town
which is quite frankly a very scary
thought village of the dam anyone
she recast pietro on the topic of pietro
dj bosnian99 says
am i the only one who feels bad for
aaron taylor johnson he's just being
left out and he wasn't even a bad
quicksilver
he just died so sokken so soon he died
so soon that's what that means now i
agree
he was not a bad pietro he actually
embodied the cockiness of the character
really well and for me
he played him closer to the version of
quicksilver
pietro that we know from the 616
better than evan peter's
characterization for the
x-men movies you didn't see that coming
now if you go with the theory
that evan peters pietro is not a
resurrection but rather a different
pietro being brought into this universe
the door is still open for a big reveal
of atg somewhere
down the line he has said in the past
that you know the door wasn't officially
closed and he would love
to work with the marvel people again in
the future
well this is that future we'll have to
wait and see you know pietro and wanda
have a close bond
and long history in the comics it would
be cool to actually be able to explore
that further but you know
if evan peters quicksilver is actually
replacing aaron taylor johnson's
then maybe that's what this is although
some people do think
that evan peters isn't actually pietro
and he's really mephisto so what do i
know
oh um it's what i'm calling the anomaly
because of its
hexagonal shape starting to catch on
bastian guggenberger says something you
should know hex or hex
is the german meaning for which yes so
of course we know that wanda's name in
the comics is
the scarlet witch but so far in the mcu
she has no alias according of course
to jimmy wu no funny nickname not a one
as many fans have pointed out there's a
bit of a red tint on a lot of stuff
going on in west view
and of course when juana turns to go
back into the hex after confronting
sword and hayward
we get a whole lot of scarlet
[Music]
so if agnes actually is agatha the witch
the witch that teaches wanda
about using magic powers then maybe
after all this is said and done
we will get the scarlet witch officially
in the mcu
you really want to go back in there
after everything she's put you through
yeah yes i do another great tease
happens during the scene where darcy
monica and jimmy are talking about how
to get back
into the hex and monica says this
i know an aerospace engineer who'd be up
for this challenge
a throwaway line for some but almost a
promise for marvel fans
sean brown says this in our comments
enter reed richards and or sue storm and
or victor
von doom yes i'm all for it this would
be a great way
to bring fantastic four marvel's first
family into the
mcu the casting for this has already
been done i mean not officially
by the fans for years we've all been
saying we want john krasinski as reed
richards aka mr fantastic
and emily blunt as to storm aka the
invisible woman they're married in real
life
they'd be married as characters on
screen it's absolutely perfect
we'll just have to wait and see if it's
true
i want to offer up though another theory
as to who this aerospace engineer friend
of monica's can be
dr adam brashear in the comics is an
engineer a physicist a genius
who also happens to be the hero of the
blue marvel one of the most powerful
superheroes
in marvel comics he's a friend of
monica's a teammate actually they both
are on the mighty avengers
and the team the ultimates when monica
is fully powered
as spectrum for me this would be an
amazing reveal and a great gift
to comic book fans and finally let's
close that off with this comment which i
think
sums things up pretty well i think this
episode made it clearer than ever that
wanda isn't
actually in control also the sword
director is
definitely a villain i mean
are we all in agreement that hayward is
a bad dude and that he's not actually
who he seems
to speak ill of people
terrorists is he mephisto is he ralph or
is he magneto with like a zorn mask
on kind of thing i don't know that's
kind of far-fetched but what do you guys
think
so many theories i love it let's get
into it even more
in the comments below if you like this
please like it
if you want to subscribe that would be
great you can also follow me
on instagram at low spot we have tons
more videos here including
which you should keep your eyes open for
which is uh the next recap
of the next episode of wanda vision very
soon after the episode drops
alright that's it for me everybody i'll
see you around peace
you